d'être avec nous pendant cette première
demi-heure et lui de l'Ardèche monte du
groupe les républicains vous présidez la
délégation sénatoriale à la prospective
on va parler du débat sur l'eau que vous
organisez cet après-midi dans les
mythique du Sénat mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est la réforme des
retraites vous êtes obtenu vous lors du
vote sur la réforme des retraites est-ce
que vous espérez vendredi que le Conseil
constitutionnel sont surtout tout parti
de ce texte non je n'espère rien et je
laisse surtout les juges
constitutionnels faire leur travail je
pense que aujourd'hui le débat
parlementaire a eu lieu on voit que la
mobilisation
continue que le gouvernement et c'est de
miser sur un essoufflement je pense que
malheureusement on n'est pas arrivé
ce que les à la fois les syndicats et le
gouvernement arrive à réouvrir le
dialogue je le je le regrette parce
qu'on est maintenant devant une
impérieuse nécessité c'est de faire en
sorte que les uns et les autres puissent
à nouveau se parler pour pour avancer
sur ce sujet qu'est-ce qui n'allait pas
pour vous dans ce texte c'est la méthode
c'est le fond de le dire ici même je
pense que la méthode je crois que le
véhicule législatif n'était pas le bon
je pense que le débat aurait mérité
d'être beaucoup plus approfondi qu'on
évoque d'autres sujets comme l'assurance
chômage comme le travail comme la
formation professionnelle je pense que
c'est un grand de société ou ensemble
qu'on met un texte beaucoup plus large
je pense que c'est un sujet qui
aujourd'hui est une est une évidence une
priorité pour les Françaises et pour les
français pour les jeunes générations
pour nos seniors également et que cela
méritait d'avoir un temps de débat plus
long vous l'avez dit Elisabeth borne
consulte elle poursuit ses consultation
et doit consulter les élus locaux cette
semaine comment quel rôle peuvent-ils
jouer de ces élus locaux dans cette
sortie de crise on l'a vu les élus
locaux et c'est pour ça que nous les
défendons ardemment ici au Sénat sont
souvent en première ligne ils l'ont été
lors des crises sanitaires ils l'ont été
dans un temps un mouvement social comme
celui des gilets jaunes je pense qu'il
mérite d'être entendu parce qu'ils
portent la voix des territoires dans
leur diversité et c'est important parce
que cette réforme des retraites j'ai
critiquée la forme mais je le vis dans
un département comme le mien l'économie
elle est arrimée à de l'artisanat à de
l'agriculture des gens qui ont eu des
carrières longues qui ont travaillé tôt
qui ont eu des métiers pénibles et donc
elle n'est pas ressentie de la même
manière dans mon territoire dans mon
département comme elle peut l'être
ressentie ailleurs et je pense que ça
aussi je pense que singulièrement ils
étaient attachés à ce qu'il y a un
traitement de la pénibilité des
carrières longues ils ont eu le
sentiment que cette réforme allait les
toucher eux qui avaient qui
travaillaient depuis longtemps et
qu'elle justement elle ne prévoyait pas
beaucoup de d'aspects qui auraient
profiter d'être traité dans cette
réforme donc les élus locaux sont aussi
ces aiguillons qui permettent d'entendre
un petit peu des voies singulières au
sein de nos territoires il est important
de pouvoir les écouter ils n'ont pas été
suffisamment non je pense je pense comme
à chaque fois on devrait partir de nos
territoires écouter ce qu'il se passe
dans nos départements parce que la
France elle est diverses aussi dans sa
capacité à exprimer des choses
différentes dans une crise démocratique
comme le dit Laurent Berger crise
démocratique je ne sais pas mais il y a
un vrai sujet parce qu'on le voit bien
c'est un sujet de de société quand on
parle
des retraites quand on parle d'une vie
de travail oui c'est un sujet qui mérite
qu'on s'y arrête et qui mérite plus de
réflexion selon moi on va parler de
l'eau faut-il revoir notre manière de
consommer de loin débat sur l'avenir de
cette ressource est organisée au Sénat
cet après-midi elle a demande de la
délégation que vous présidez on va faire
le point avec notre journaliste
parlementaire à l'expousa
[Musique]
Alex bonjour Yann bonjour monsieur
d'Arnaud et le Sénat va donc débattre
cet après-midi de la gestion de la
ressource en eau alors que la France est
frappée par des épisodes records de
sécheresse mais oui cette année on a
connu un mois de février sans pluie
c'est l'un des hivers les plus secs en
France depuis des décennies alors au
mois de mars la pluie est revenue mais
pas partout les nappes phréatiques ne se
sont pas totalement remplies et certains
départements sont en vigilance
sécheresse actuellement avec et bien la
carte de france du 7 avril et les états
d'alerte sécheresse en jaune les
départements en état de vigilance en
orange les départements en état d'alerte
où il y a déjà des arrêtés de
restriction d'eau il y a même des
territoires en état d'alerte renforcé et
puis dans le département des
Bouches-du-Rhône certains certaines
communes sont en état de crise c'est à
dire qu'on est au niveau de restriction
d'eau maximale alors et bien voilà on
est donc quand même dans une situation
assez dramatique dans notre pays
aujourd'hui et malheureusement Alex
c'est pas nouveau cette sécheresse
cette sécheresse touche notre pays
depuis des années en disant le nombre de
cours d'eau asséché à plus que doublé en
2022 la France a eu 3438 cours d'eau
asséchés alors que 10 ans avant et bien
on était à 1515 en 2022 on est quand
même à 20 % de cours d'eau à sécher donc
c'est un chiffre qui est inquiétant et
puis cette sécheresse elle est appelée à
durée les experts estiment que dans les
prochaines décennies et bien la France
va perdre jusqu'à 40 % de sa ressource
en eau il y a donc urgence et face à
cette urgence et bien le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron a annoncé il
y a des jours un plan de sobriété de la
gestion de l'eau tous les secteurs vont
être mis à contribution on va l'écouter
nous allons demander à chaque secteur un
plan de sobriété sur l'eau d'ici à l'été
les ministres réuniront dans les
prochains jours dans l'ensemble des
secteurs concernés
l'énergie l'industrie le tourisme les
loisirs l'agriculture ça marche bien
quand tout le monde sait l'évolution de
la situation quand tout le monde est
responsabilisé et quand on sait que les
efforts sont partagés alors ce plan haut
annoncé par le chef de l'État va aussi
mettre en place d'autres mesures comme
une tarification progressive de l'eau ça
veut dire que les derniers mètres cubes
de la consommation de la consommation
moyenne d'un français et bien vont être
un peu plus cher qu'aujourd'hui pour
inciter les Français à faire des
économies des projets locaux vont être
lancés pour retraiter les eaux usées
c'est une des grandes lacunes de notre
pays aujourd'hui un plan d'urgence est
également prévu pour résorber les fuites
de notre réseau d'eau et puis le
président de la République a estimé et
qu'il fallait je cite des changements
significatifs dans nos pratiques
agricoles puisque l'agriculture et le
premier consommateur d'eau du pays et en
tout cas Emmanuel Macron n'a pas remis
en cause les méga bassines dont on parle
actuellement beaucoup en ce moment
notamment avec les manifestations autour
du un projet de Sainte-Souline Matthieu
d'Arnaud est-ce que ce plan haut est à
la hauteur de l'urgence en termes de
sécheresse en termes de sécheresse qui
touche actuellement notre pays non
clairement s'il y a des choses qui vont
dans le bon sens et en cela qu'elle
reprenne les conclusions et les
préconisations du rapport que nous avons
commis ici au Sénat je pense notamment
au traitement des eaux usées je pense à
plusieurs sujets comme le stockage de
l'eau de l'eau de pluie la mobilisation
de la ressource et quelques moyens là où
le bât blesse c'est sur le plan
financier sur le plan financier parce
que quand on annonce un renforcement des
crédits des agences de lots à hauteur de
475 millions d'euros mais que les années
qui viennent de s'écouler ont vu ces
agents cette prélevés de 400 millions
d'euros pour financer l'Office français
de la biodiversité je dis que le compte
n'y est pas on est face à un défi
colossal je crois qu'il faut bien qu'on
en prenne la mesure et au Sénat nous
alertons depuis maintenant plusieurs
années sur ce sujet avec des rapports
successifs qui pointent du doigt le
manque de financement et je crois que ce
plan haut en est l'illustration nous
avons besoin de plus de financement pour
être à la hauteur des enjeux on vous
dites il y a un problème de budget en
termes de sobriété d'efforts les efforts
qui sont demandés par le Président de la
République à tous les secteurs est-ce
que c'est la bonne démarche bien sûr que
la sobriété elle est importante mais
elle n'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga d'ailleurs j'observe
que s'agissant de la sobriété les
agriculteurs ont commencé
à faire des efforts en matière de
sobriété que sur les territoires moi je
viens d'un département particulièrement
frappé par ces questions de sécheresse
où on a mis en place avec les
établissements publics de bassins un
plan sobriété qui s'appelle Ardèche 2050
donc on se projette pour faire en sorte
que la consommation d'eau soit de
raisonner qu'il y ait plus de pédagogie
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens des usagers
de l'eau pour justement faire oeuvre de
sobriété mais il ne faut pas opposer la
sobriété à la mobilisation de la
ressource et à ces mesures comme
notamment les retenus colinéaires encore
une fois penser à de façon à conjuguer
les usages qui vont finalement des
usages agricoles touristiques concernant
des départements comme les miens sur la
défense incendie pour faire en sorte
qu'on soit plus en phase avec les
objectifs environnementaux et que l'on
respecte plus l'environnement mais là il
y a pas de défense supplémentaires qui
sont vendeuses agriculteurs de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron il a raison vous dit
qu'ils en ont suffisamment fait ils en
font il faudra sûrement en faire encore
mais il faut penser ce sujet avec la
profession je pense que comme je l'ai
dit c'est un sujet qui est un sujet
essentiel qu'on peut largement comparer
avec la crise énergétique que l'on vient
de vivre à ceci près
risque
finalement de devenir une problématique
pérenne et malheureusement avec laquelle
il va falloir composer parce qu'on sait
bien qu'on va avoir une baisse
significative des précipitations et
qu'on va avoir des épisodes de
sécheresse à répétition et que ce plan
haut arrive bien tardivement je vous
rappelle qu'en janvier 2022 nous avions
déjà un débat au Sénat qui s'appuyait
sur un des rapports de notre
collèguerémy pointeau qui disait que
l'eau finalement selon le selon pardon
le sacro-saint principe ne payait plus
l'eau mais l'eau payait l'État et ça
c'est un vrai sujet je crois qu'il faut
aujourd'hui mobiliser des financements
qui sont beaucoup plus importants que
ceux annoncé dans ce plan haut est-ce
qu'il faut aussi augmenter
progressivement le prix de l'eau c'est
ce qui a annoncé le président de la
République faire payer plus cher les
dernières derniers m3 de la consommation
moyenne ça participe de l'effort de de
sobriété mais encore une fois il faut
regarder les choses de façon
différenciée moi je me méfie toujours
vous savez de ce principe de la moyenne
où on traite les territoires de la même
manière on voit que le sujet ne se pose
pas de la même façon dès lors que l'on
est sur des zones de montagne que l'on
est sur des zones de plaine que l'on est
sur des territoires où les nappes sont
déjà pour partir à sécher et donc il
faut vraiment qu'on ait une lecture fine
de ce sujet et je me méfie de ces effets
d'annonce qui ne sont pas suivis de de
lendemain concrets fines Clément vous
dites c'est pas au chef de l'État de
décider de la tarification progressive
de l'eau ça doit rester à la main des
collectivités ça je pense que c'est
important parce que c'est ceux qui
connaissent le mieux le territoire c'est
ceux qui connaissent le mieux l'état de
la ressource et c'est ceux qui sont en
capacités aussi c'est le plus important
de mettre tous les acteurs autour de la
table les acteurs du monde agricole les
acteurs du monde économique on aurait pu
parler aussi du nucléaire parce que
quand on dit que ce sont les
agriculteurs qui consomment le plus il
faut aussi parler de la question
économique du nucléaire et ne pas
opposer les uns aux autres mais les
mettre toutes et tous autour de la table
pour pouvoir avancer sereinement et con
qu'est-ce qui fait que notre pays est à
la traîne dans cette gestion de l'eau on
a finalement un faible taux de
retraitement des eaux usées 1% alors que
certains pays comme l'Espagne ou
l'Italie sont à 10 ou 20% de
retraitement des eaux usées on a
également de beaucoup de fuites dans
notre réseau d'eau qu'est-ce qu'il fait
qu'on a tous ces problèmes mais je pense
qu'encore une fois nous avons pas su
anticiper en oppose trop facilement les
uns aux autres dans l'utilisation on n'a
pas anticipé notamment la question de ce
qu'on appelle les réseaux fuyards les
fuites sur sur les réseaux parce qu'on
manque clairement de moyens pour autant
on a qui se sont là pour le coup ce sont
les collectivités qui n'entretiennent
pas suffisamment le réseau c'est d'abord
le manque de moyens avec l'État en ce
que je dis on a un principe l'eau doit
payer l'eau et donc les collectivités
doivent avoir plus de moyens les agences
de l'eau qui sont censés financer
aujourd'hui ne le font pas suffisamment
à tel point par exemple dans mon
département de l'Ardèche c'est le
département de la collectivité
départementale qui notamment pour
l'élaboration de ce qu'on appelle les
schémas directeurs de l'eau est obligé
d'int vis-à-vis des collectivités ça ne
va pas je le dis on est devant un défi
qui se pose en France comme ce défi
s'est posé dans d'autres pays comme
l'Espagne comme cela va se poser dans
l'ensemble des pays d'Europe ce qui est
un fait nouveau c'est classé Shrek qui
est assez vie sur notre pays l'année
dernière en 2022 a révélé que c'est
l'ensemble de notre pays qui est
concerné là où on avait plutôt le
sentiment que c'était le car sud-est
les les départements qui sont le plus
exposés à la chaleur aujourd'hui cette
sécheresse elle frappe et elle frappera
encore plus fortement demain notre
territoire c'est pour ça qu'il faut
qu'on ait une prise de conscience et
c'est pour ça que ça doit être une
priorité absolue pour l'État et bien sûr
pour les collectivités mais qui sont
déjà largement mobilisés sur ce sujet
mais juste vous dites l'eau doit payer
l'eau est-ce qu'il faut que le prix de
l'eau soit plus élevé est-ce qu'il faut
que les français payent l'eau plus cher
pour que les collectivités et plus de
moyens où il est très bas voir quasiment
gratuit bien sûr qu'il faut qu'il y ait
un effort mais on est dans des
territoires ou à contrario l'eau est
déjà très cher c'est pour pour ça que je
dis attention à cette logique de moyenne
il faut vraiment regarder avec une
maille fine chacune et chacun des
territoires pour apporter des réponses
encore une fois concrètes plus de débats
place aux actes quand on voit les
enfrottes les affrontements qu'il y a eu
à Sainte-Souline contre ces méga
bassines est-ce que vous craignez une
guerre de l'eau dans notre pays à
l'avenir non mais c'est pour ça qu'il
faut des passionnés le débat il faut
aussi avoir recours un peu plus à la
science dans ce qu'elle peut nous
apporter de solutions c'est pour ça que
j'ai parlé de retenue
multi-usages d'ailleurs j'aime pas ce
terme bassine pour capter et pour
stocker l'eau de pluie que l'on remet à
disposition
finalement de notre écosystème après
donc il y a un moment donné où il faut
être en capacité encore une fois de
multiplier les usages pour être plus
efficace et plus respectueux de
l'environnement
on parlera de la jeunesse mobilisée
contre la réforme des retraites ce sera
à suivre dans le clavier Alex on va
parler toujours des élus locaux les
démissions des Luc locaux atteignent un
niveau jamais vu c'est ce que dit David
Lisnard le président de l'Association
des maires de France 1293 mère ont
démissionné en trois ans ce qui a dit
Christophe Béchu le ministre des
collectivités territoriales il a promis
de mieux accompagner les mères qu'est-ce
que vous attendez de cette phrase
je pense que c'est à Christophe Béchu de
nous dire ce qu'il compte faire pour
agir là encore une fois ça fait depuis
maintenant plusieurs années depuis la
mer le décès malheureusement de du
collège mère dans le Var assis ou avec
Philippe banne nous avions lancé une
grande concertation avec la commission
des Lois du Sénat qui pointait déjà du
doigt les violences physiques verbales
notamment par le biais des réseaux
sociaux dans son victime l'ensemble des
élus de France du conseiller municipal
jusqu'au maire et il est urgent
effectivement d'agir les élus on le
répétera jamais assez sont dépositaires
de l'autorité publique ils mènent pour
beaucoup une mission
j'allais dire essentielle pour le
développement de nos territoires ou les
voky en préambule de cette entretien
aujourd'hui ils vont être concertés par
la première ministre c'est bien le
reflet finalement
du poids qu'ils ont dans notre pays et
du rôle
qui aujourd'hui fondamental pour animer
nos territoires faire vivre nos communes
et répondre aux aspirations dans un
temps parfois agité de nos concitoyens
donc je pense qu'il faut mieux les
protéger il faut aussi repenser c'est ce
que nous allons faire avec la mission
d'information sur l'avenir de la commune
ici au Sénat donc je suis le rapporteur
travaillé sur la question des conditions
d'exercice des mandats locaux notamment
pour ressusciter des vocations rappelons
quand même que ce sont dans une immense
majorité des bénévoles les élus locaux
encore une fois qui sont au service de
leur territoire parce qu'ils sont
attachés alors commune parce qu'il est
il représente finalement ce premier
maillon ce premier service public et
parfois le dernier dans nos communes
c'est pour ça qu'il est important encore
une fois de les protéger de les soutenir
et de leur donner des moyens pour qu'ils
exercent dans les meilleures conditions
leur mandats mais lesquels parce que
David Isnard ils pointent plusieurs
problèmes alors il y a bien sûr la
question des violences et des
incivilités mais pas que ils parlent
aussi du harcèlement textuel il y a trop
de normes c'est trop
prochainement la multiplication des des
réunions et comment aussi on essaie
effectivement comme le disait le
président de l'Association des maires de
France David bisnard faire en sorte que
on réfléchisse
l'inflation normative il y a eu avec la
délégation aux collectivités du Sénat un
séminaire qui s'est tenu une charte a
été signé entre l'État l'Association des
Maires et le Sénat pour réfléchir à ce
sujet je vous rappelle qu'il y a quand
même un texte qui avait été voté ici
pour faire en sorte que quand on crée
une norme on en supprime deux nous
espérons que l'Assemblée nationale
pourra peut-être demain donner suite
parce que c'est un travail collectif
nous sommes toutes et tous
pris de bonnes intentions à un moment
donné il faut mettre ces bonnes
intentions
que ces bonnes intentions se traduisent
en acte et c'est là ce que nous avons à
faire je pense dans les semaines et les
mois à venir et la remise de votre
travaux c'est fin juin vous viendrait
totalement nous en parler on va aller
dans votre département pour terminer
voir l'actualité du côté de l'Ardèche et
de la Drôme avec Carole Raynaud bonjour
Carole merci d'être avec nous chef
d'information de la Drôme Ardèche à la
rédaction du Dauphiné Libéré on se
projette sur la semaine avec vous Carole
puisque le Congrès de la Fédération des
Chasseurs de l'Ardèche aura lieu en fin
de semaine oui bien sûr on va parler
vous savez cette semaine de la deuxième
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites mais pas seulement vous l'avez
dit samedi au Pouzin se tient le Congrès
de la Fédération des Chasseurs de
l'Ardèche il faut savoir sur le
département on compte cette année très
exactement
9516 adhérents donc la chez nous c'est
très important et puis on va vous parler
d'un partenariat d'une convention
inédite qui ne s'était jamais faite sur
le département de l'Ardèche où le
président du conseil départemental
Olivier Amrane mais 150000 euros sur la
table pose sur trois ans avec la
Fédération de la chasse pourquoi pour
deux objectifs pour soutenir la chasse
accompagnée vous savez ce dispositif qui
s'ouvre aux jeunes à partir de 15 ans
avec un accompagnement pendant un an sur
la pratique de la chasse avec un
chasseur aguerri et puis améliorer la
sécurité de la chasse donc c'est un
dossier important qu'on sort on fait le
point aussi sur le nombre de sangliers
tués pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce
que en un an il a pris il y a 20% de
sangliers qui ont été tués en plus sur
le département parce que les chasseurs
Martels le président de la Fédération
ont un rôle dans la régulation des
populations qui commet pas mal de dégâts
on le sait sur nos communes alors moi
j'avais une question pour le sénateur
d'Arnaud monsieur le sénateur on oublie
cette idée de interdiction de la chasse
le dimanche
à titre personnel j'y suis j'y suis
opposé et je pense que vous avez
finalement fait le meilleur plaidoyer
pour la chasse dans notre département a
commencé par cette convention qui va
être signée entre le département et la
Fédération de la chasse qui vise
notamment à traiter un des points qui a
fait débat et qui fera vraisemblablement
débat qui est celui de la sécurité et je
pense qu'il n'y a pas finalement
meilleur acteur que la Fédération de la
chasse d'un côté et la collectivité qui
veut accompagner cette cette démarche je
rappelle aussi qu'il y a beaucoup de
d'efforts qui sont faits de la part de
la fédération départementale de la
chasse pour sensibiliser les jeunes et
notamment les collégiens aux questions
de la biodiversité de l'environnement
donc je pense que ce sont plutôt là des
actions vertueuses il faut les
accompagner travailler à ce qui a fait
débat et ce qui a notamment amené
l'exécutif à réfléchir autour de ce jour
nonchassé du dimanche je pense que c'est
pas nécessairement la bonne façon de de
vrai
très bon libération du camp de buenwald
ouais c'est un dossier passionnant puis
je peux en dire deux mots on a on a un 3
mois qui a déni chez ça sur Internet
c'est marrant le choc des générations et
il a retrouvé donc le carnet d'un
déporté et donc on a un témoignage qui
est Squeezie chez vraiment je vous
invite à lire notre journal ça vaut le
coup vous pouvez vous avez 30 secondes
pour vous en dire un peu plus Carole
voilà l'histoire d'un d'un monsieur qui
avait 26 ans à l'époque on a appris
qu'il a réussi à sortir du camp vivant
c'est quelqu'un qui est finalement
décédé chez lui à La Rochelle mais il
aura contre quelques jours en fait avant
la libération par les Alliés et les
Américains que tout s'agitent dans le
champ de bouquet de Vald et que les SS
essayent de les faire évacuer et se met
en place une espèce de résistance de se
déportés qui ne veulent pas partir et
qui veulent être libérés on a des
passages qui sont
retranscrits et franchement ça vaut le
coup de voilà de regarder ce qu'on a
fait de se casser notre notre
journaliste Amandine Brioude sur le
sujet et c'est à l'air dans le Dauphiné
un petit mot Mathieu d'Arnaud un
formidable témoignage et je pense que il
est important justement et je remercie
le Dauphiné de l'avoir fait de pouvoir
sensibiliser les lecteurs mais plus
généralement la population
par rapport à ces événements tragiques
de l'histoire et encore une fois c'est
une chance que d'avoir pu retrouver
cette ouvrage